[Music]
today we cancel the publication called
scientific american now the scientific
american has been around for a very long
time uh since the mid-1800s in fact it's
one of the very oldest media outlets in
the country and for much of that run it
was considered credible and reputable a
trustworthy source for science-related
news a great number of famous scientists
have written articles for it over the
years even albert einstein can be
counted among its contributors
but those days are over albert eins
albert einstein is long dead and if he
were not dead today he would wish he was
because the far left religious cult has
infiltrated and corrupted nearly
everything in society especially the
media and the field of science so if you
combine those two things in a scientific
media outlet
you're sure to get the worst of both
worlds and that is certainly the case
with scientific american case in point
this week the outlet debuted the the
second episode in their docu-series
titled a question of sex
in a tweet thread about the series
scientific american makes clear that the
purpose of the documentary is to debunk
the myth of the two sexes the myth they
say
yes sexual dimorphism one of the most
fundamental concepts in human biology
and something that no credible scientist
anywhere in the world ever in history
have ever questioned
is now a myth
in an article on the website about the
documentary it's explained that the sex
binary is false
because of the existence of intersex
people we're told quote intersex is an
umbrella term for variations in
reproductive or sexual anatomy that may
appear in a person's chromosomes their
genitals or internal organs and it has
been estimated to include about 1.7
percent of the population there are more
than 30 medical terms for different
combinations of sex traits that fall
outside of the typical male and female
paths of development
now the article goes on to explain that
the alleged existence of these 1.7
percent of internet intersex people
throws the whole notion of the sex
binary into question the article ends
with a quote from a so-called intersex
activist named sean cipher wall and it
says
after all the fixation on a sex binary
in science wall points out doesn't occur
in a vacuum quote i think for people
asking the question is your child a boy
or a girl i would really challenge them
to just take a moment and ask why why is
it so important are you just happy to
have a baby are you just happy to start
a family i think those are quality of
life questions that often get overlooked
or missed in this conversation
yes why do you care if your child is a
boy or a girl
why do you care if your child is human
why do you care about any of the basic
physical details of your child
why can you raise and parent him as if
he was a an ambiguous nondescript
lump of sentient matter pretend that
he's just an amorphous puddle of cells
in dna that's all that matters
makes perfect sense
a clip from the documentary provides
more
completely imaginary by the way details
let's watch
while gendered social structures are
ancient a binary framework of biological
sex didn't actually exist in western
culture until the late 18th century
before science recognized only one sex
the male and considered the female body
an inferior version of it
the shifts that historians call the two
sex model served mainly to reinforce
gender and racial divisions by tying
social status to the body
okay so let's go over a few things here
first of all we must always keep in mind
that the only reason anybody ever talks
about intersex is to validate
transgenderism that's the only reason
scientific american is running this
series it's the only reason
they jam intersex onto the pride flag
it's the only reason they include
intersex in the lgbt alphabet soup
intersex is a medical condition that has
nothing to do with lgbt
but it's included and in fact given
pride of place
simply because people who suffer from
this particular genetic deformity are
useful to the trans agenda never mind
that trans and intersex have nothing in
common
and that the existence of intersex
people does not even come close to
validating the claims and
self-perceptions of trans people but
it's important to understand why they're
talking about intersex at all because
then it makes sense
um why they lie about it so much
for instance in the passage from the
article that we read
they say 1.7 of people are intersex
now if you're a person with common sense
you hear that figure
and you feel immediately skeptical
1.7
really i mean that's still a minority
percentage-wise but that would translate
to like
six million people in this country alone
are there really six million intersex
people walking around in this country
well no
that number is a lie
because everything these people say is a
lie
they lie with abandon about everything
all the time
colin wright looked into this this
subject a couple years ago
and discovered that the 1.7 figure comes
from a book written by a woman named ann
fausto sterling who had an ideological
axe to grind she wanted to disprove the
sex binary and she did it by wildly
inflating the number of intersex people
that exist in the world reading from
writes column it says they broadly
define an intersex person as quote
an individual who deviates from the
platonic ideal of physical dimorphism
at the chromosomal genital gonadal and
hormonal levels
to arrive at their 1.7 figure
they asked how frequently humans deviate
from this platonic ideal in the review
their ideal male is defined as somebody
with xy chromosomes
functional testes located in the scrotal
sac a penis between 2.5 and 4.5
centimeters at birth and a completely
enclosed urethra that opens at the tip
the ideal male must also have testes
that produce malaria inhibiting factor
as well as testosterone and
dihydrotestosterone there we go and
juvenile testicular activity must result
in typical masculinizing puberty their
ideal female has two x chromosomes
functional ovaries that result in normal
feminizing puberty intact oviducts
attached to a functional uterus cervix
and vaginal canal the ideal female must
also have labia minora and majora
present and a clitoris that ranges from
0.2 centimeters and 0.85 centimeters in
length at birth
okay
you see the problem hopefully
they are including in their definition
of intersex people
um people who deviate from their
definition of the platonic ideal
and yet whose sex is not at all
ambiguous or in question so they came up
with what they consider to be the
platonic ideal of maleness and anyone
who deviates from it slightly is
intersex
so a male
who is clearly and unambiguously male
and yet has a smaller penis than normal
penis or problems with the testes or the
urethra ends up counted as intersex by
their definition
this is just completely ridiculous
and that's why if you apply a more
precise definition of the word intersex
you find that the actual number of
intersex people is lower than point zero
two percent that is one hundred times
less than the estimate scientific
american
provided and when you realize that the
actual intersex population is so
miniscule the attempts to use it as a
chainsaw to cut to pieces the sex binary
become even more obviously ludicrous
intersex people are anomalies they
suffer from an unfortunate medical
condition their existence does not
destabilize or throw into question
the notion of biological sex as we've
always understood it
we are still left in a world where
everybody in principle either has the
capacity to get pregnant or the capacity
to impregnate others
now disease deformity or old age may
interfere on an individual level with
those capacities but the principle
remains
just a few days ago i read a story about
a um
a two-headed kitten that was born in
arkansas
now it's an interesting and sort of
grotesque medical anomaly but does it
mean that we can no longer say kittens
have one head
must we now define kittens as creatures
with multiple heads
must we start talking about kittens like
they're mythical beasts like a kitten as
a hydra from greek mythology
no of course not
now what about the claim in the video
that the sex binary didn't exist until
the 18th century and before that there
was only one sex well
um that's just pure fiction that's
invented on the spot and with nothing to
support it
read literally anything anything at all
i mean seriously anything
written at any time before the 18th
century and this claim falls apart all
at once the book of genesis was written
thousands of years ago and yet says at
the very beginning
male and female he created them
indeed every ancient religion has an
account of creation and they all account
for the creation of males and females
not one sex not three not seven not 52
not an infinite variety but two
because that's all there was at the time
or is now or ever will be
now i would say more to debunk this
particular claim but it would be like
trying to debunk the claim that
watermelons are actually dragon eggs and
if you sit on them a baby dragon will
hatch
it's just there's not much that can be
said to refute a purely fictional claim
invented out of whole cloth and with not
the slightest bit of evidence to support
it worse than having no evidence
actually all of the evidence we do have
and there's a lot of it directly flies
in the face of what they're saying
everything we know about ancient history
and about past and current non-western
cultures confirms beyond any shadow of a
doubt that the sex binary is not a
modern western dimension
gender fluidity is the modern western
invention
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really that's what it
is we're joined we're forming a cult
then all you got to do is click the
subscribe button and ring the bell below
uh this video to stay up to date with
all my content and if you want even more
you can watch or listen to my show at
thedailywire.com spotify or apple
podcast looking forward to welcoming you
to the sweet baby gang